Hello. Hi there. Hello, sweetheart. My name is Sheevy Cottonbomb. I'm your mistress and the
madam of Wonderland. I bet you enjoyed Emmy's debut. Isn't she just the cutest? Hope she didn't
put too much of a spell on you. Okay, well, now you do well to behave and listen. However,
first things first, we're gonna practice some obedience. So I'm gonna have you try
something for me. Can you say aha or type A's in the chat?
Good job. I'm so proud of you. Okay, so hold on. Let me just come and set up my desk. So yeah,
I know my desk is messy. I'll clean it off later. As mentioned, my name is Sheevy, but you must
refer to me as Madam or Ms. Sheevy, if you like. My surname may sound silly to you, but it's a known
fact in my family that we have buns of steel. My last name just showcases that. I was born on
September 28th, which just happens to be Monday. My parents just seems to have really gotten the
timing right, I suppose. I am pretty tall in my family at 168 centimeters. That's a five, six,
and a miracle if you didn't know. I'm a lap and polla, otherwise known as a bunny girl. You see,
I have a lovely set of floppy ears in this picture right there. I can also DJ like I just can't
I have the many characteristics of a rabbit, like my stamina, for example. I'm also very good at
jumping and have quite the vertical. My family is mad at me, though, because I didn't pick up
basketball like a distant relative of mine. So my age, that's really quite rude of you to wonder.
And although I might have some motherly qualities, I'm not old enough to be your mother. In human
languages, I only fluently know English, but pleasure doesn't really need words, does it?
I'm also fluent in bunspeak, but my accent and pitch, it really only comes out if I'm excited.
So normally it sounds like this. But I get really excited talking to you guys, and this is very rare.
This is what I sound like. So let's look at my likes and dislikes. So first of my likes,
I really do enjoy a wide range of music genres. I can't sing well, but I try my best and I just
try to have fun with it. Huge fan of really any sort of techno with bass and thump, you can really
feel anything that makes me move. Besides country, the only good songs to come from country are
Ram Ranch and Save a Horse Ride a Cowboy. I'm not the pickiest eater, but I do have my favorites.
I love love love a seafood. I'm a woman of opulent taste, lobster. My mother also always prided in
how well I ate my veggies as a wee rabbit. I even like Brussels sprouts. I love fa and Spanish food
as well. And I have a few junky comfort foods like Uncrustables. I f***ing love Uncrustables
and Puppy Chow. I have that really rarely though, because you know, I gotta keep up with this nice
figure. So from my hobbies, when I'm not in the dungeon, I mean managing the Wonderland Hotel,
you can catch me reading a book, practicing my knots. As you can see, I do jujitsu. One time
during a jujitsu class, I accidentally put a pier to sleep with just my thighs. Whoopsies. I do
watch a lot of anime, but I'm probably kind of labeled like a normie for my taste. I recently
watched Dungeon Meshie and Three Rin, you know. If the theme is really sci-fi or fantasy, I like it.
Like Firefly, Stargate, Star Wars. I'm a freaking nerd. Don't tell anybody though. I have to keep
up an air of mystery. Some games you'll see me play will be like meta-ish games. I love Inscription.
I like Souls Likes like Elden Ring. I like Liza P. I really want to dive into more retro games.
I also like RPG story-driven games like Elder Scrolls, horror games like Alien and Amnesia.
And I recently discovered I like Relics like Halt of the Lamb. I'm embarrassed to admit this.
I played a lot of FPS growing up like Counter Strike 2, so I'm trying to widen my horizons.
Let's just not talk about my 600 plus hours. Okay, these are kind of self-explanatory.
Don't play your music too loud. Nobody else wants to hear it. I don't like being in really large
crowds. It just freaks me out. I don't like when somebody disobeys me. Do not disobey me.
Don't like when people correct me. I'm the one giving correction. All right. And I hate getting
interrupted during any sort of playtime, and I hate when people put things in the wrong place.
It's there. I like organized chaos. So here are some of my goals. I like to beat a Souls Likes
on stream. I'd be in Elden Ring already, and I'd be in Liza P. Offstream, but you know,
I would like to do something with you. I would like to learn another language because
everybody else is super cool, and I'm not, and they all know other languages. So I want to have
a video hit 100k views and hit 10k subs because if I reach those milestones, I know I'm doing
something right and that you guys are enjoying my content. I want to go to a convention as a
robot like they're doing at off-key right now and be like, hey, and just try to like hit people
with it. I think that'd be really fun. I would love to release another cover. You guys will see
that we have covers coming up. Mine's not good, but you know, we can try again. I would love to
voice in an anime or some other form of animation. I would love to travel, off-clad with the girlies,
and I want to make amazing friends in other companies, you know? There's a lot of amazing
talents out there that I would love to get to know. Here's my general art tag. This is Sheebie
Art. We're not going too crazy with it. My alternative, my naughty art tag is Abundage.
Memes are Bunwild. My live is Sheebie Live. Clips are a cotton bum clip. And my fan name,
we're going to pick it together in my 2.0. I came up with harem this morning.
Myoshi Marks are a rope and a bunny. It's pretty self-explanatory. Okay, so my first impressions
of the girls, I put like where I would take them on a date. So first, Rani, she's hardworking,
and I know she loves Lord of the Rings. So we're watching all of the Lord of the Ring
movies together while we snuggle. Mercy, I would take her to a steak house
because knives. She's dangerous. She lives life on the edge. Get it? High fedge.
Azura, I want to cook a meal together with her and take her in a picnic. Probably something milk-based.
I think she'd be able to provide that. Getting ice cream with icy would be amazing.
If we could just watch the sunset, you know, all the aurora borealis. We go back to her hometown.
For Amy, I want to take her to a coffee shop with a bookstart and feeder pastry. She's so
cute. I just want to stuff her little face with food and then find her more grimoire so she can,
you know, get her bro back. I don't really know what they got going on, but it's something. I want
to give a huge thank you to SquishyGoogle and Nari. They did such an amazing job. If they hadn't
done all the work that they did, I would not be here. None of the girls would be here. And here
is also a thank you to all these other wonderful people who, without their help, I wouldn't have
all this cool stuff. Like, thank you. Guys, work so freaking hard. I appreciate it so much. Okay,
let's go to my bedroom. I can shut myself off. Hello. Hi. You can see my beautiful face. I'll
go through. Hold on. Let me just... So you got my beautiful feet. My little stompers. I'm gonna step
on you with them. My long, luscious legs covered with my beautiful tights. And then, you know,
naturally I'm wearing shabar roads. But don't get it twisted. Just because I'm tied up doesn't mean
I'm not going to be the one calling the shots. Okay, sweetheart. All right. Somebody asked,
does these ropes leave marks? Yes. I like to wear a really lacy lingerie. I mean,
this is just a shirt. It's just a normal shirt. I don't know what you're talking about. And then
my lovely choker. It's very avant garde, don't you think? And then we have my beautiful face. I'm
gonna quickly run through my toggles. We got blushing. We got sweating and blushing. We got
hard eyes sweating and blushing. I can be really, really dark if you disappoint me. I'd be really
upset. My love, did you do that? Piece of shit. And I can try. Which is rare. So I'm not gonna use
that for long. I can have a real mouth. And then I can be like, holy crap. When were you gonna tell
me you're so small? And then I can question my life choices. Have a leash. Yeah, you're on my leash,
baby boy. I can also bop you. So be good. You're not gonna like where this goes. At long last,
the time for edging is over. Release roof links and feast your eyes on the lovely Scottish
fish, straw me. Give her all my love.